hallo leute ich sie teure mal wanne und
wenn ich es nicht mitbekommen habt ich
habe letztens ein video hochgeladen das
heißt street ein warum ich nie wieder
eine deutsche bahn betrieben wird und
mit diesem video bin ich in die
deutschen youtube trends gekommen mein
großer traum ist wahr geworden ich bin
in den trends naja eigentlich war schon
kann man trennen und gar nicht ein paar
mal in den trends war stellt sich nun
die frage wahrheit und lüge liegen oft
nah beieinander sind die trends wirklich
nur müll oder haben unsere redakteure in
einen bären aufgebunden ihr johnson
frank willkommen bei x-factor x-factor
das unfassbare
schauen wir uns doch die trends einfach
mal an was haben wir hier satz eins in
den trends eminem rips donald trump in
bet hip hop awards freestyle davon habe
ich heute im radio gehört ja ich in
einem parkhaus
okay das erste video schon mal kein müll
ein punkt für die trends 2 auf den trend
star wars jedi trailer habt ihr euch den
letzten star wars angeguckt also dieser
stars der als erstes raus kam ihr wisst
welche nicht meine ich habe den gesehen
ich war nie ein großer star wars fan
welche überraschung aber ich fand den
echt gut nur mich juckt dieser trader
hat überhaupt nicht ich finde den auch
extrem langweilig also klatscht mich
jetzt nicht so aber ist auch keinen müll
platz drei auf den trend wieder auf der
fibo von aaron also ich muss sagen ach
und macht jetzt nicht den geistlichen
content aber er macht jetzt nicht nur
scheiße also platz drei ist doch auch
irgendwie verdienen hallo ich finde
deine videos lust platz vier auf den
traffic tactical lucy warum wird ein
lustiges video vorgeschlagen was zehn
sekunden lang ist okay das ist ja
richtig ist schon witzig aber ob es
jetzt in die trends gehören auf dem
fünften platz ist ein video wo man sagt
typisch dass das in die trends com ultra
wohnung update komplette montur naja gut
sie konnten es jetzt auch einen
marseille scorpio zeigt seine wohnung
ich finde auch geil wie die ganzen ruhm
tue man gleich anfangs sehr der filmt
eine tür klopft und machen macht der
andere auch als ob man so bei mtv cribs
wäre ja hallo leute das ist mein hobby
wohnung ließ work am kopf kommen sie
rein im eingangsbereich hat er schon
seinen youtube button hängen ersten
statement würde ich sagen ist jetzt kein
avi video na also es halt room to 2 star
wars in die trends geschenkt bekomme ich
auch schon vor die helfer die alle
diesen trailer so feiert aber
jeder findet stars cruise meine anti
star wars armee
sie ist wahrscheinlich nicht so großen
grauen gibt's auch in den trend jeder
liebt krank oder oder oder oder das ist
schon der 42 von diesem spiel da muss
ich ja sagen ich find let's play ja auch
nett und ich finde auch cordes cool und
so aber wie kann man sich 42 teile davon
anschauen jemand ein spiel spielt das
sieht aus wie super mario smash brothers
ist wahrscheinlich auf ein paar marius
ebbers ja das ist definitiv super marios
bruder ja es ist schon witzig aus aber
52 teile davon
common bank kommt jetzt endlich das
erste typische trend video was wir
vermisst haben herrn nackel auf der
hauptschule bruder was typisch
hauptschule obama ich schwöre die so
heißt es ist so eine mischung aus
sketchen und we live tv rtl 2
bedarfsfalle und so einen minecraft
video der kelly effects anklänge und
cache lang gar nichts zu bieten
ihr habt es bestimmt mitbekommen es ist
ja auch nicht so schwer wenn alles
darüber reden mit youtube in manchen
dahinter ganz richtig videos mit anderen
youtube an zahlen sich für den eigenen
kanal sehr aus und dabei ist der kelly
effekt überhaupt nichts neues gefühlt
seit dem youtube existiert machen
youtuber mit anderen youtube an zusammen
videos damals vor allen dingen weil sie
halt einfach wurde videos machen wollten
aber jetzt mit klinkern beef anzufangen
er stellt es so dar als ob kelly dass
nach so ein business profil gemacht
hätte aber tatsächlich sind ja nur ihre
freunde also wirklich ihre freunde in
den videos also in diesem kelly wird das
youtube deutschland monat länger an wenn
du willst das ist meine ansage ich
schwöre ich mach dich kalt die
peinlichste mutter facebook trolling von
kuchen dvr hab ich hab nichts mehr von
tv gehört überhaupt meine freundin
heiratet ein teil i bleib ich muss ja
sagen ich bin großer fan von ihm und
ihrem freund mag die beiden einfach
kennt ihr das so wenn diese paare seht
hier einfach super sympathisch findet
und denkt genauso bin ich auch
irgendwann sein minecraft minecraft
polizei berlin tag & nacht also darauf
andere geht nina brändle
berlin tag & nacht sendet jetzt auch auf
youtube muss ja gestehen ich habe berlin
tag und nach seinen anfängen ziemlich
regelmäßig geschaut und wusste auch
immer was abgebt später habe ich nichts
mehr davon mitbekommt die videos haben
wir richtig gute aufrufe läuft dir
richtig ist auch perfekt
sie konnte gehört auch natürlich in die
trends das ist so typisch tritt also ich
muss mal sagen der anfang von den
trainern ist zwar viel aus ausland und
fiel gar nicht so deutsche labview
günther die halt was tolles macht sind
aber sind aber jetzt nicht so schlimm
also es jetzt nicht so also das geht ab
irgendwann lol einfach mein körper
minecraft um einen gott gibt es wirklich
so viel minecraft auf youtube ich dachte
mir das ist nur so was was man sagt so
höher minecraft let's play eine
türkische sendung erinnert ihr euch noch
an die zeit wo es halt nur türkisch
wendungen gab also vorgeschlagen wurden
dieses icings crack video ist einfach
noch mal in den trend mit suhler beim
friseur runde beim friseur das muss in
die trends bei reverse xxl slawski fuß
ist dieses real food versus gummi was
ist das für ein trend gerade ich
verstehe es nicht was für ein
unterschied soll man daraus kriegers das
heißt jetzt ag das heißt du nimmst
echtes essen und gummi essen das
eigentlich wegen nach gummi das andere
nee das ist der unterschied werde google
myself boeing-chef ist so witzig studium
kann jetzt mit seinem kanal polieren sie
einfach diese ganzen youtube videos
machen diese ganzen standard youtube
video hier in den letzten jahren
verpasst weil er hat ja nur seine red
schon sowas gemacht hat macht einfach
datenpool ein video kann er sich zum
schein links machen sich selber googeln
der kann sich von seinem girlfriend
schminken lassen oder seien gar für ein
schminken oder so und wer ist denn dort
ich finde auch nicht dass ich mit diesem
video die trends gehören immer wenn ich
youtuber verarsche oder irgendwie so ein
youtube-video mache kriege ich mal so
viele daumen ich glaube immer dass die
hälfte es nicht check kann aber auch
sein dass nicht einfach scheiße finden
was er auch in ordnung ist hier müssen
sich alle meine videos feiern aber ich
muss aber ganz ehrlich sagen wir machen
diese videos so spaß wenn ich andere
youtube videos für apple deswegen würde
es nicht mal interessieren wie ihr es so
findet trends gibt trends der woche ich
will dass gerade zum ersten mal ein
fazit zu den youtube trend ja sie sind
nicht wirklich trend wie man sie sich
vorstellt coole videos die ein vater
gewöhnlich teufel aber es ist jetzt auch
wirklich nicht nur an die content es ist
viel wein kraft wirklich viel minecraft
es ist viel ausländisches zeug was ein
vielleicht nicht wirklich so
interessiere aber sie konnte
hab ich jetzt nicht so viel gesehen wäre
allerdings cool wenn die trends auch so
eine möglichkeit wären für kleinere
kanäle dass man vorgeschlagen wird dass
man vielleicht reichweite er bekommt was
als kleiner youtube-kanal halt noch
schwer allerdings war das für ganz viele
leute schwer ich habe zwei jahre videos
gemacht die kaum jemand gesehen hat bis
dann irgendwann so der stein ins rollen
kamen kann nicht erwarten dass man mit
youtube anfängt und nach einem 2 3
monaten irgendwie schon wirklich
reichweite hat mein tipp für euch immer
am ball bleibt eigentlich auch
aufgefallen dass die teams gar nicht
mehr so an sie sind oder glaubt ihr
immer noch nicht trennbar sie kein bock
drauf scheiße bis dahin tschüss